اهلا نورتينا في اهلا وسهلا صباح النور
والسرور ما هذا الصوت الجميل وهذا الاحساس
الاجمل فخليني ابلش معك من هاي النقطه
كتير يا حبيبي عليك هذه تعبير الوجه وانت
عم تغني هذا الانسجام والطرب والسلطنه وفي
ذات الوقت احاسيس بالفعل صادقه بتوصل
للمتلقي من وين جايبه كل هذا العمق في
التعبير
اول شيء انا سعيده صراحه بالاستحسانك
وسعيده مره بالمشاركه
المشاعر الاحاسيس اللي تيجي لما اغني لاني
احب الاغنيه نفسها فخلاص يعني انا
بدون ما احس نفسي ادخل ابحر في الاغنيه
فاعيشه اعيشها
اروى خليني اسالك انه اليوم الجيل الشباب
بسم الله ما شاء الله عليك انت صغيره يعني
جيل الشباب وربما يروح الى الاغاني
السريعه ايقاع الشيخ شكشكه وغيره وين رحتي
الموشحات ليش طلال ليش ام كلثوم ليش الدقه
القديمه مثل ما يقولون
ما اعرف لكن ترى من وانا صغيره وانا يعني
احب اسمع
ام كلثوم والورد الجزائريه الصغيره
طلال مداح طارق عبد الحكيم الله الله يعني
عبد الباسط عبد الصمد يعني احب اسمعهم
واحب اقلدهم
اهواكي كلاسيكي
يعني احاول الصراحه
حاولي والله احاول اني ادخل في الاغاني
الجديده
تركي الاغاني الجديده انا انا ابي طرب ابي
شي يهز القلب
حابين نسمع شي منك يا اروى يلا تمام
يلا ابشروا ابشرين اتفضل
قصيده قديمه
لحنتات الحان محمد عبده لحن لحن طلال مداح
لحنها بلحم ويوسف المطرف فانا راح اغني
بطريقة يا الله هذا احبه ومطرب
[موسيقى]
قف بالطواف ترى الغزاله المحرمه
الحجيج وعاد يقصد زمزما
[موسيقى]
بالطواف ترى الغزاله المحرمه
حج الحجيج وعاد يقصد زمزما
بدر اذا كشف اللثام رايته
القمر المنير وعظم
[موسيقى]
ابهى من القمر المنير وعظم
عند طواف رايتها متلاثما
للركن والحجر اليمني
عند طوافر رايتها متلاثما
للركن والحجر الياباني
سالت بالله العظيم لتخبريني
ما الاسم قالت من سلاله ادمان
سالت بالله العظيم لتخبري
ما الاسم قالت من سلاله
ادمان
ادمان الله على فكره ترى ايضا
تحطينها في لحن رابع على فن الصوت اعتقد
اعتقد صوت عربي قديم بالتاكيد هذا تسمعينا
اذا عرف ان الصوت ايضا غنوها
حكينا على ليش انت بتحبي الاغاني
الكلاسيكيه من الكلاسيكيات انو الاقرب الى
قلبك اكثر ام كلثوم
من يعني فنانين العمالقه وفنانين الزمن
الجميل
كده ما راح اخلص ترى احنا ما بدنا نسمعك
تغني اكثر
[ضحك]
احنا ما نبيش تخلصين طيب بس اقول لك يعني
من الفنانين اللي انا
الفنانين اللي انا مره احبهم مره انا
متاثره فيهم
طلال المداح انا اصلا بديت شهرتي باغنيه
من طلال مداح اللي هي اجانب كل الهواء
وقتها اصلا لما انا غنيتها ما كان احد
يعرفها يعني نادر كانوا النخبه النخبه هم
اللي يعرفونها طب سمعينا اياها يا اروى
الناس
وصار صار الكل يسمعها جميل اجمع كلنا سمع
بس مجهزين مجهزين قولي قولي بخاطرك يلا
توكلي على الله اللي تبيه لا لا عادي عادي
اللي تبينه
في موشح انا مجهزته صراحه يلا
لكن اللي يعني احنا احنا نشكرك ونخلي لك
مقاليد الهواء ونقول شكرا جزيلا والهوى
كله لك
بعد
الله يخليك يلا ختامها مسك واروى
تفضل
[موسيقى]
يا اهيل الحي من وادي الغضب
وبقلبي مسكن
انتم به
ضاقع الوجد بكم رحوب بالفضاء
لا ابالي شرقه من غربه
فعيدوا اهدا انسي قد مضى
تعتقوانكم من كربه
واتقوا الله
واحيا مغر
نفسا في نفسي
وطار ما فيه منها عيب
سوى انه مر كلامح البصر
سدد السهم
وتم ورمى
ففوا دينهبه
المطرسين
والذي اجرد
دموعي عندما
عندما
ارتب غير سبب
[موسيقى]
على صدري يمنى كفى فما اجدار الماء
باطفاء لها
اجدارا الماء
لها
اجدار الماء
[ضحك]
نشكرك يا اروى الفنانه السعوديه اروى
السعوديه على
الالحان الجميله وهالصوت وكل توفيق يا
اروى الله يخليك الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات